buonasera a tutti mi chiamo vinicio
marchioni ho 44 anni
molti mi conoscono per i film che ho
fatto per la serie che ho fatto molte mi
conoscono perché ho fatto la regia di
alcuni spettacoli con cui sono stato
anche qui e con cui ritornerò per mia
moglie sono l'uomo che di cui si è
innamorata dieci anni fa per i miei
figli sono il loro padre per mio
fratello sono il suo fratello per mia
madre sono ancora sua figlia come tutti
quanti noi insomma no agli occhi degli
altri
che cosa siamo però io quando devo
pensare a me quando devo definirmi a
parte tutte queste cose qui mi viene
sempre da da pensare a me e mi definisco
come un ball come un balbuziente
quindi questo ted durerà due ore e mezza
mettete ricordo perché mi viene questo
non lo so perché sono 40 anni che ci
convivo con questa cosa
sono 40 anni che cerco delle strategie
per ovviare a questa cosa non sono uno
studioso non sono un logopedista non
sono uno scienziato sono semplicemente
un uomo che sono 40 anni che convive e
che studia analizza questo questa
anomalia sicuramente che cos'è la
balbuzie non lo sa nessuno
sono 20 30 anni che qualcuno fa degli
studi cerca di individuare il gene che
ci può essere all'interno di noi che
ereditariamente si trasmette non c'è uno
studio scientifico che ci dice che
questa cosa si è così c'è chi pensa che
sia ereditario perché ovviamente lo
sviluppo linguistico avviene attraverso
l'imitazione quindi ascoltando mio padre
che anch'esso era un balbuziente forse
ho imparato a parlare in questo modo qui
c'è chi dice che a che vedere con la
psicologia nel senso che a che vedere
con delle insicurezze con la ricerca di
affetto da quando siamo piccoli nei
confronti di nostra madre di nostro
padre eccetera ma la verità è che
nessuno sa un cazzo sulla sulla balbuzie
la verità è che non esiste una tipologia
di questo fenomeno simile ad un altro
cioè non esistono due persone che si
impicciano alla stessa maniera
nel mondo c'è che si impiccia sulle
iniziali
c'è chi si impiccia sulle sillabe cece
sillabe
c'è chi si impiccia si impiccia si
impiccia ripetendo la parola e lì a dire
che così ciechi semplice su alcune
consonanti iniziali che su altresì chi
sulle slf la mlb eccetera eccetera
questo che cosa provoca provoca che non
si possono avere dei dati non si possono
avere delle cose tutti danno per
scontato che il fatto di imparare a
pronunciare delle parole sia semplice si
inizia di prime parole si dice mamma
papà merda
kakà in realtà non è proprio
semplicissimo il file linguaggio
prima di tutto perché è l'unica cosa che
ancora ringraziando il cielo si
distingue dagli anni ma dagli animali
l'essere umano ha imparato a
decodificare a comunicare tra di noi
attraverso un linguaggio che è una cosa
enorme ragazzi su cui noi oggi abituati
a scrivere a comunicare ad avere una
mole di informazione velocissima ogni
secondo diamo per scontato che possiamo
dirci ciao buongiorno come ti chiami
come da dove vieni come il tuo nome chi
a tua madre che a tuo padre
questa cosa è l'unica cosa che fa
dell'essere umano un essere umano ed è
una cosa su cui riflettere insomma
quello che ho capito in questi 40 anni e
che la balbuzie secondo me è un arte è
l'arte di imparare a parlare per tutta
la vita perché io ancora oggi non sono
in grado di parlare ancora oggi devo
concentrarmi ancora oggi devo mettere in
moto tutte le conoscenze che ho imparato
durante gli anni di studio dic
recitazione di scuola per parlare
davanti a voi ad una platea così senza
avere un ruolo da recitare era una cosa
difficilissima succedono molte cose
nella vita di chi acquista anomalia nel
senso che vedendola da fuori ovviamente
far ridere o c o cibo ci colpisce ogni
tanto ci viene da finire noi la parola
della persona che stava per che sta
parlando però chi sia questa anomalia
per tutta la vita cerca delle strategie
cerca delle strade nuove per dire quella
parola lì questo molto spesso significa
che se io sono in pizzeria con gli amici
a me piace tantissimo la capricciosa
porca miseria solo che mi impiccio sulla
capricciosa ordinerò per tutta la vita
la margherita perché è fluente perché
non mi impiccio
se io devo invitare a cena fuori o aprì
per il primo appuntamento qualcuna o
qualcuno non le dirò attiva di andare a
prendere un perché nel tempo che io devo
dire caffè lei già mi sta prendendo in
giro io sono diventato rosso vorrei
sprofondarvi per terra e allora gli dico
di vasi andiamo a prendere un tè anche
se il te mi fa schifo
queste cose succedono davvero un'altra
volta per sé mi serviva da ragazzino
dovevo lavorare ne servivano dei soldi
quindi la cosa più semplice a cercarsi
dei servizi extra come cameriera ok mi
presento da un tizio io non mi presento
mai non perché sia un antipatico ma
perché in impiccio sulla v
quindi per dire il mio nome ci metto un
quarto d'ora quindi per non presentarmi
con il con il nome di vinicio gli dico
che mi chiamo cia un piacere su un
andrea lui mi assume perché ovviamente
non volevo farmi vedere che mi impiccio
perché andare ad un tavolo prendere un
ordine parlare con il cliente mentre rim
pc non è proprio la cosa più semplice
del mondo quindi mi chiamo andrea lavoro
a un certo punto mia madre chiama che
non mi chiama mai nella vita chiama
perché era successa una cosa dentro casa
non lo so chiama il proprietario ore
risponde mia madre cerca ovviamente
vinicio il ristoratore ovviamente gli
dice che non c'è nessun vinicio lì
dentro torno a casa e mia madre si
incazza perché pensava che fossi andato
a drogarmi da qualche parte gli avessi
detto una bugia queste sono tutte delle
piccole cose che succedono e su cui
magari nessuno riflette su chi soffre di
questa anomalia di questa cosa ne soffre
in un per cento della popolazione
mondiale che non è proprio noi quanti
siamo qui più o meno siamo più di cento
a parte me che sono un balbuziente
forse c'è qualcuno con qualcun altro che
ci ha dei problemi di affluenza si dice
così con un termine molto poetico anche
che cosa succede da piccoli per esempio
succede che la prima cosa che i genitori
vanno in ansia da morire perché
ovviamente ti trovi davanti qualcuno che
dedica una grossa difficoltà e
immediatamente pensi che tuo figlio è
fragile immediatamente pensi che il tuo
figlio sia debole immediatamente pensi
che tuo figlio verrà asfaltato da una
società che va di corsa
il problema è che questa ansia il figlio
lo assorbe tutta semplicemente mentre
invece il figlio che c'ha 34 56 anni è
un bambino e parla come parla se ne
frega che si impiccia perché è un
bambino non ha ancora la coscienza la
consapevolezza il giudizio è l'analisi
di individuare i segnali che gli
arrivano dall'esterno
crescendo i bambini sono violenti sono
cattivissimi sono delle merde e quindi
ovviamente si creano delle situazioni
difficili a scuola però io se tornando
indietro mi ricordo soltanto che io davo
delle grandissimi capocciate dietro sul
muro perché ovviamente era un po timido
mi vergognavo un po di questa cosa e mi
mettevo all'ultimo banco dietro per gli
spasmi che avevo mentre parlavo davo le
capocciate al muro però al di là di
questa cosa non è che io stavo da solo
morto ammazzato e non giocavo ero triste
ovvero il piccolo fiammiferaio andava a
fare dei compiti giocavo a pallone per
strada non ero escluso non ero
emarginato dico questo perché negli
ultimi due o tre anni sui social mi
scrivono moltissime persone che hanno
questa anomalia perché io non so sono
diventato quello che ce l'ha fatta sono
diventato quello che è riuscito a fare
l'attore
non credo di essere riuscito a fare
niente ancora lo dico per chiarezza nei
confronti di tutti però è importante
comunicarle alcune cose alle persone che
stanno a scuola quei ragazzi adolescenti
che vengono presi in giro che
insomma per tutto il discorso degli
haters del del bullismo che c'è in giro
ho preso degli appunti perché non mi
ricordavo niente assolutamente e che
secondo me bisogna lasciar fare un po
alla natura molto spesso mi sono
informato in 40 anni di vita ne ho visti
tanti di discorsi motivazionali di
ricorsi di specialisti e la maggior
parte di questi finisce sempre con la
frase straordinarie che dice dalla
balbuzie si guarisce anche con un tono
molto emotivo no empatico che è quello
che si vogliono sentir dire la madre il
padre di tutti i balbuzienti del mondo è
una cazzata dalla da questa cosa non si
guarisce mai semplicemente perché questa
cosa da un'anomalia del modo di parlare
si trasferisce ad hanoi in una anomalia
del modo modo di pensare cioè io mi
impiccio perché formulando la frase so
che devo dire una parola con l'abi per
esempio e quando arrivò a dire questa
parola con la b mi impegnerò sicuramente
perché già lo so il mio
il mio pensiero per sviluppare una
strategia di comunicazione si è
sviluppato velocissimamente quindi so
esattamente dove andrò ad impicciarmi
quando arriva quella parola mi impiccio
è un cane che si rincorre la coda in
maniera incredibile
il problema è molto complesso nel senso
che se io sto da solo dentro la camera
mia non mi impiccio
io prima stavo giù nei camerini ripetevo
queste cose che mi sono scritto ed ero
fluente figo arrivo qui a me cago sotto
e quindi molte persone dicono il
problema sia quando si entra in
relazione con un altro no però la mia
domanda che mi sono fatto in 40 anni è
ma se io sto con la mia compagna che mi
ama mi accoglie sono tranquillo perché
mi impiccio
se io sto con la mia compagnia di amici
con cui esco da 15 20 anni che mi
conoscono
mi prendono un po in giro però fa parte
del gioco perché mi impiccio
il problema forse non è la relazione con
un altro
il problema è chi sono io chi sono io
dietro a questa cosa che si chiama
balbuzie
perché questa cosa che si chiama così
arriva prima prima arriva molto prima di
me e le persone conoscono me attraverso
questa cosa e io sto dietro e che sono
io dietro a questa cosa chi sono io se
non balbetta sì io non lo so come sarei
se non avessi questa anomalia
il problema forse è fatto tre minuti
come sappia l'ansia di questo tempo che
arriva vede perché il problema
esattamente questa è una sincronicità
rispetto a un ritmo abbiamo sentito
prima quel signore del della merda che
ha fatto così per 15 minuti e non mi
sembrava normale no una cosa così eppure
parlava fluentemente milanese parlava
della merda così il problema che un
balbuziente non ha un ritmo interno non
l'ha trovato e il problema forse
semplicemente togliere il problema di
focalizzarsi l'ansia di chi parla in un
pubblico avendo questo problema sin da
piccolo è spostare questo pensiero ma è
cercare di concentrarsi su un flusso sul
fiato sulla respirazione sulla
conoscenza dell'apparato fonatorio sul
respiro perché siamo tutti diversi non
c'è una persona al mondo che allo stesso
timbro di voi
non c'è una persona al mondo che allo
stesso ritmo di parlata non c'è una
persona al mondo che ha la stessa
cadenza di parlata di un altro e quindi
io sono diverso rispetto a cosa parlo
diversamente se i miei mi impiccio un po
di più di voi ma non sono diverso
rispetto a chi sa che l'esperienza
teatrale mi ha aiutato semplicemente
perché mi ha dato la coscienza di me
quando dico che il teatro mi ha salvato
la vita non è una frase fatta durante le
interviste mi ha salvato la vita perché
mi ha dato un'identità mi ha fatto
conoscere degli strumenti che spostano
ai miei occhi il problema e mi ha dato
la struttura per poter essere qui
davanti a voi e poter parlare piu o meno
fluentemente cercando di convincerli che
se vi trovate davanti ad una persona che
è che non è fluente
tenete conto che lui ha una cosa molto
più grande di voi o che usa una cosa in
una maniera molto più profonda di volo
che si chiama ascolto chi ha un problema
con con con qualsiasi tipo detto che a
qualsiasi problema che a qualsiasi
problema tipo di problema con il
linguaggio ascolta di più
guarda di più osserva di più e osservare
non è guardare osservare significa avere
un tempo di riflessione dopo avere
urtato un balbuziente è una persona che
sa perfettamente conosce la fisiognomica
delle persone che ha davanti a sé
semplicemente perché uno strumento di
comunicazione diverso da quello che usa
la maggior parte delle persone è
semplicemente perché in 30 20 40 anni ha
dovuto trovare un'altra strategia per
capire con chi poter parlare
quindi se vi trovate se vi trovate
davanti uno che si impiccia quando parla
dategli retta un po di più semplicemente
perché fatto lui di conoscere di piu di
quanto voi possiate conoscere lui ea chi
si impiccia dico un'ultima cosa
chi vi è chi vi ama chi ha tempo chi si
fida di voi chi ha capito intuito che
dentro di voi c'è qualche cosa troverà
il tempo di ascoltarvi non prendetevi
l'ansia che arriva dal mondo
chi non vi ascolta chi se ne frega lui
si è perso qualche cosa non certo voi la
sinistra
[Applauso]